poor old
our pats looks like a pile of garbage
i'm afraid
hi i'm toby capwell i'm curator of arms
and armor at the wallace collection in
central london but i'm also a
practitioner since i was a kid i've been
riding horses and fighting in armor
i've taken part in competitions armored
combat all over the world today we're
going to be looking at the treatment of
medieval arms and armor in cinema
[Music]
oh stop stop did you see that
he just got shot in the armor and it
knocked him but it didn't stop him and
you know in a complete armor
a medieval knight can suffer horrendous
physical punishment
that would kill an unarmored person
like that but you can take the hits and
in armored combat
there are times when you decide to let
your opponent hit you
because you know you can take it and
you're going to do something else you're
not going to waste time defending what
doesn't need to be defended and the
armor in this clip takes on
again narrative significance it's
storytelling
he can take a shot right in the chest
that's a pretty big character point
wouldn't you think he's not clunking
around all cumbersome he moves like a
real knight i've been jousting and
fighting in armor for 30 years you know
i built a lot of different kinds of
armor working with different craftsmen
all over the world real armor of the
late middle ages the renaissance is like
a steel skin
it's not bulky
it's your shape the armor should fit you
like a skin it should follow your
musculature
it doesn't have to be a lot of space
under there it's fitted it moves with
you the plates are hardened and tempered
medium carbon steel so they don't have
to be thick and chunky
they need to glide over each other and
move
like you move
tell me where the mandalorians are and
i'll walk out of here without killing
you he hardly ever takes his helmet off
and yet you know everything about his
expression his feelings his character
historically a knight
has a very close personal relationship
with his armorer the armor is
responsible for his safety
but he's also
the guy who's going to mold your
character that's never really been
explored
you know until this i said where are
they
it's got a couple of possible sources of
inspiration on the one hand it looks a
lot like an ancient greek
popolites helmet the ancient greek heavy
infantry of like 500 bc of thereabouts
these these very distinct spectacled
helmets with these like eye cutouts the
nasal for the nose and then the cheeks
brought in in the bronze age they're
trying again to get as much protection
for the face and the head as they
possibly can so that's where that really
closely set kind of spectacled
profile comes from
that was then imitated in the
renaissance you know in the 15th century
in italy and
very rapidly everywhere else people were
became fascinated with the classical
world again and they started looking
back to the ancient greek and roman
precedent
and this style of helmet became
fashionable again in italy and venice in
the venetian empire specifically in the
15th century
most used by infantry
shooting crossbows and firearms and more
lightly armored troops
and in the ancient greek period they
they were the heavy infantry but
they still had shields to hide behind
and they're actively protecting their
faces as well as
as well as relying on their armor i'd
give this a 10 absolutely
vikings is a fantasy
you should really treat it as a fantasy
there's a lot of things to like about
this
show and that makes it almost the more
tragic for me because those anglo-saxons
are all wearing late 16th century
helmets
the berganettes with the high comb and
the peak
they are
800 years wrong
the leather biker gear
there is almost no historical evidence
for leather clothing almost across the
board people in the past did not make
clothes out of leather it's a distinctly
modern thing
the axe is fine i don't have a problem
with the axe i do have a problem with
none of the main characters wearing
helmets you can't go anywhere near a
battle like this without a helmet so i
mean someone like ragnar lothbrok or
someone of that stature would have
amazing male coat he'd have jewelry he'd
have big thick gold stuff on him he'd
have a gilded sword he does not have to
look like a pile of leather crap
i'm gonna give it a three
could not be undone
that is metal
nothing else
looks like metal but metal in close-up
all that decoration
is etched into the steel with acid
this is film armor as good as it gets
now there are lots of great spraying
techniques and you can spray plastic to
look reflective and increasingly it
looks more and more like metal but it
doesn't behave like metal their armor is
a little you can see it's a little bit
too flexy
something about
metal that
it has a weight it has a rigidity
that rubber and plastic and polyurethane
don't have
he walks into the in into the battle and
you know everything you need to know
about this guy and it's all coming out
through his gear they've taken real 15th
century armor styles mostly german
and then turned it up to 11. sauron is
wielding a mace
and mesa is a real it's a hafted weapon
with a wooden or a steel haft with a
flanged or bladed head on one end so all
the weight of the weapon is balanced to
the end and it's a concussion weapon and
you're trying rather than to cut or
pierce your opponent you're trying to
smash through their defenses that is way
bigger in proportion to him
than any real maces were
real german gothic
high medieval maces
of the 15th century
are um they're usually pretty short
they're like just a little bit you know
more than a foot or a bit more long the
heads are quite small but they got these
really sharp blades on them and you
focusing your energy
on a really small area a weapon doesn't
need to be massive to have the effect
that it needs to have
but massive always reads well on screen
especially when you've got a dark lord
of mordor and and how successfully does
it use armor and weapons
to bring its characters and its themes
across
i got to give this 10 as well
poor old
our pats looks like a pile of garbage
i'm afraid this is a mishmash
there are a couple of elements the
shoulders and the body armor
that are vaguely 15th century
but they're about a generation too late
for agincourt his helmet is just
ridiculous i mean that has a vaguely
16th century profile to it but it fits
badly it's too big it's clunky
oh come on man what is this
well this is obviously
supposed to be the battle of agincourt
in 1415.
at the real battle of atchin court it
was very muddy the french had ten
thousand fully armed nights that was the
entirety of their army they had archers
but they didn't use them the pada calais
mud is like this thick gluey clay stuff
very difficult to move through
and it would be difficult regardless of
what you're wearing armor often gets
blamed for the french defeat at
agincourt as if the french were wearing
heavy armor that the english didn't were
too clever to wear or something the fact
is the english including henry v here
were wearing full plate armor of the
time the english had 1500 fully armed
nights whose job it was to protect those
famous archers
they go about it sort of the right way
in that this knight is someone who's
been trained to fight and kill people
since he was a child and he's very very
good at it
the only way you've got any chance of
this if you're an archer an english foot
soldier or whatever is to get six or
seven or eight of your friends
and pile in all at the same time don't
take turns he will kill all of you you
gotta all go together
and four or five of you got to hold him
down and then one or two of you have to
stab him in the eyes and in the gaps in
the armor you don't stab through the
armor when
king richard iii was killed at the
battle of bosworth they immobilized him
they held him down
someone took his helmet off they
probably cut the chin strap and took the
helmet off and then they can do as they
like they cut off the back of his skull
they stabbed him right through the brain
they did whatever they wanted i'll give
it a one because they've got mud and
archers working together but i can't
give it any more than a one it's it's a
it's a massive lost opportunity
[Applause]
it's a legal procedure
where
they're determining the ownership of
territory
with a trial by combat they're attacking
each other on the wrong side if you can
see they're passing right to right which
is wrong they shouldn't be doing that
because your rain hand is in your left
hand
so
it can't wield a weapon your rain hand
is in your left so your left side is
more exposed so that's where your shield
goes your lance is in your right hand
nobody's allowed to be left-handed in
the middle ages in traditional nightly
mounted combat like this you always pass
from left side to left side unhorsing
someone is very difficult
and it only happens when certain key
factors all come together the timing's
got to be right the impact the placement
of the lands on the body's got to be
right
where he is in his stride of the horse
when he gets hit all those lots of
things that kind of contribute to the
likelihood of being unhorsed but as a
general rule it's very
very difficult
to separate a good horseman from his
horse
if this was a later period in in like
the 15th century full plate when you
have full plate armor you can be run
over by a horse in full plate armor and
you'll be just fine i've seen it happen
this is kind of a weird choice
in this film because el cid rodrigo de
vivar was a real person
but he lived in the 11th century
in the late 100s
it's largely looking like the early to
mid 14th century
uh oh
the 16th century two-handed swords are
coming out now
we assume for some reason that a bigger
sword hits harder than a little sword
that you know these are not firearms
this is not a higher caliber sword
you know they didn't have two-handed
swords in in el sid's lifetime what
you're seeing charlton wearing here
is what's
traditionally referred to as string male
it's a knitted garment knitted with big
knitting needles
so you've got big loops in the in the
weave of the knitting and then they iron
it flat spray it silver and it looks
like male or they think it does it
doesn't really look that much like male
but it's it's been the male substitute
for years and years and years
and it's fine
you know for the background and i'd
still pass it for the background but you
can't have it in the foreground
five out of ten
a diving suit is is very much like armor
in the sense that it protects you from a
hostile environment of a different kind
it's a complete fantasy
because he's not got an air supply
diving suits are a real historical thing
there are designs going back to the 14th
and 15th centuries in the late middle
ages
of designs for diving suits the skills
of the armor
would be
recruited
for doing something like this they work
purely on a basic system of of water
displacement the suit is not water tight
the water can get in you pump air into
the helmet and it displaces the water
below your face
but the water as the pump is going up
and down the water goes up like this
and it sometimes covers your face and
sometimes goes down and you hope they
pump hard enough to keep you from
drowning it's dicey but it's possible i
give it a 7.
it's very very interesting
hey what's he doing stop that
oh
can't do that that's not how you take a
sword apart i'm sorry
this whole idea of melting a sword blade
down and then
recasting it in a mold which is what
they're doing
um you can't do that if you reduce the
the iron or the steel to its liquid
state
you lose all of the properties that you
want if you melt and cast iron in a mold
it's cast iron
and it becomes really brittle and you
can't temper it and you can't heat treat
it you know when you have a lump of iron
ore as it comes out of the ground
yes they heat the iron ore
to to separate the iron from all of the
silicates and the the rest of the stuff
that it's mixed up with you never fully
melt it you don't bring it up to the
full melting point you heat it up until
the chemical reaction occurs in the ore
which separates the iron from all of the
other junk
and it sort of gloops down into the
bottom of the bloomery weaponsmiths are
very very careful never to fully melt
anything you cannot melt armor down and
make new armor i don't care if it looks
good on screen it's dumb
i like some of the things that that game
of thrones does with armor but that's a
fail that's a zero
i love this sort of evil statue of
liberty sort of
you know aesthetic here
i think the the star of that scene is
the flail real flails are derived from
farm implements the articulated staffs
that are used for threshing wheat and if
you have a feudal peasant army and they
need to take whatever
hurty things are to hand a flail
you know agricultural implements are
good it's a staff with just an eye bolt
articulation and then another piece of
wood when such an idea is weaponized
more extensively
they add a short length of chain
between the staff and the head flails
almost exclusively are a lower class
common soldier infantry weapon the
knights didn't use them because they're
kind of scary
and they have
an inherent mechanical
intrigue
they've become
much more famous and much more popular
to the kind of
popular conception of the medieval night
than than they really deserve to be
but it's great here i mean again it
totally works here no flail was ever
that big no flail ever had a chain that
long but
in this context it works great i can't
think of another weapon
that would have the kind of
visual and story
character driven impact
that this has in this scene
it's got to be a 10 out of 10.
he'd be dead
he'd be very dead one man can't attack a
shield wall like that
nobody ever used rectangular shields i
mean that's ridiculous
it's stupid and real early medieval
shields which were all circular as far
as we can tell if air can get through
then a lot of other things can get
through
most reel shields of this period are
made out of
uh of boards placed
edge to edge
sort of like this
but they're placed properly edge to edge
and they're glued
and they're sealed and you know there's
there's arguments good arguments to be
made for them then being edged with
rawhide or sometimes covered with hide
or
textile and glue you should not be able
to see that much air through your shield
[Applause]
he's been stabbed right through the
chest between
those plates they're showing you
how their own
made-up silly armor doesn't work
you know now maybe if he gets hit full
in the chest with a spear
that's wielded by someone who knows how
to use it his padded textile and male
armor
which is what he should be wearing or
even maybe a scale arm or maybe it
wouldn't stand up either no i can't i'm
sorry i can't find anything to hold on
to that's a zero
[Music]
badlands technique i'll give them a pass
on that because they wouldn't have known
what goodlance technique is
it's a very common thing in jousting
sequences in movies
that
they lower their lands
to a horizontal
and then they kick on and gallop along
and they're galloping along
with their lance on the level you don't
do that you're sitting on a horse you've
got 12 feet of pine lance and the horse
is going up and down like this and
you've got it here it's inevitable that
it's going to start to do this
and pretty and it's got a steel head on
the end there's weight right out on the
end of that and pretty soon this thing
is going up and down and you couldn't
hit a you know a barn door with the
thing you've got no chance of
controlling where that spear goes and
you get the horse going and then you
don't have to worry about your opponent
until the last second or so of the
interaction
and then it comes down boom
it takes practice if you're too late you
miss if you're too early you get tangled
up and look like an idiot
but if you get it right you're always
you're always on a lance came down it
got tangled up with my lance and a joust
and it came down and the steel spearhead
which has three prongs like this
two of the prongs went past my hand
and the third one bypassed the defenses
of my armor the gauntlet it went just
under
the plate through the leather gov and
into me
i finished the competition before i even
realized i needed to go get sewn up
yield sir i have the advantage now again
this is all metal armor it's all
aluminum
aluminum split sprayed black or aluminum
polished but look how good it looks they
worked hard to do what they were doing
and they knew what they were doing and i
think it deserves a 7.
[Music]
traditional ranged weapons like the
longbow and the crossbow
you know the projectile
you know isn't moving that fast but it's
still moving way fast enough
you can't you can't block arrows
remove the hood in the mask
[Laughter]
it's an interesting outfit he's got on
you know who's he come as
he's got a vaguely
11th or early 12th century helmet
but he's got full plate armor under
there like the 16th century or something
i'll give it a two because it's funny
and it's nicholas cage
oh that's funny
i guess that's worth something